pollsters have been asking about
impeaching President Trump for some time
in the latest Harvard Harris X poll
42% said that he should be impeached and
removed from office for his actions
while 41% said no action should be taken
there have been only a few ripples in
this trend since Harvard Harris first
ask the question in June 2017 another
question with a different emphasis asked
by Quinnipiac University since January
this year provides a different
perspective in August twenty eighteen
fifty-eight percent of registered voters
said that they would not like to see the
Democratic Party begin impeachment
proceedings if the Democrats regained
control of the House of Representatives
in November thirty six percent said that
they should proceed a majority of voters
in the June 2018
NBC News Wall Street Journal poll said
that their vote in November would not be
a signal either way on impeachment 22
percent said it would send a signal to
impeach Trump while a similar 25 percent
said it would send a signal in
opposition to impeachment this is a
sensitive issue with serious political
ramifications let us know what you think
and let us know your comments also let
us know what other topics you'd like our
scholars to cover in 60 seconds and be
sure to subscribe for more research and
videos from AEI